[Music]
new bridge over and I'm Tara Ericsson so
much more exciting my intro was in his
terawatts Game of Thrones as well I
watch Game of Thrones
I love Game of Thrones you kidding who
doesn't you don't love it get out you
get out don't watch this video
mark here if you don't like game of the
season 7 trailer by the way we have a
video on her channel that we did
together go check it out my favorite one
is George or Jorah Jorah yeah the one
who's always like golly gee please ah I
have been loyal to you call easy very
tight any city you sit and to the south
used to the moon war please do me
[Music]
I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
[Music]
a burger triggers a zone it's a
commutation staff last best health
looking for coming storm
[Music]
if we don't put aside our energies and
bound together we will die
[Music]
well it doesn't matter who skeleton sits
on the item
[Music]
Oh
yeah the great wall is he
we're finally in the Great War oh my god
I'm Lea in the war it's cold man it's so
so it's been up it's been a while oh
I've missed the dragon so much it's been
a long time I am sorry kid
I love carrying Lannister I love him so
so much Terry owns my favorite he is my
favorite and I love that he's he's he's
with Khaleesi right now still right man
yeah owning no he's on her side that's
what I'm saying you know he's like with
her still Cobra
date him no he's just not because of his
height he's a drunk that's why it would
be unhealthy yeah I would be way too
unhealthy because he's getting drunk and
you're trying to do it cuz he's drunk I
gotta say though production Wow the
production is that looks like a movie
yeah like this I feel like it always
kind of looks like that oh well but I
heard they were throwing in more money
and yeah taking their time when it's
been a long time since yes so come back
yeah cuz they wanted to up the quality
because now we're going into this is
epic war territory yeah I think they
really want to make it look like movies
World Cup epic war Braveheart [ __ ] a
Braveheart Lord of the Rings kinda yeah
we're like Rome did you guys ever watch
Rome on HBO that was a good one that was
so good and it cost them so much money
just to make that one yeah season that
they like couldn't afford to do it
anymore now Game of Thrones at season
seven they can have as much production
value I think as they would want a need
so now they're probably just like cool
we can probably milk it now which is
awesome I want to see some serious black
[ __ ] and blood and guts and Dragons
I tried Ragan's you look better in fact
who do you think's going to win from my
understanding the show's already packed
the books right now I never read the
books I've read all of them really I'm
that intelligent well I read all
time he's lying I don't watch TV every
only reading this brain absorbs I'm
already asleep
I wonder Cersei will die this season
this as we've seen a seventeen yeah but
Cersei right now is ultimate enemy [ __ ]
yeah going on and I love her yo you're
the katja loser as a character right
hates that because she's the ultimate
villain I say should I have right now
you know or they're all going to come
together to take on the White Walkers
right now cuz that they all have a
pretty common enemy and that's them
Cersei needs to fight them to what they
really been building up to is Daenerys
being the queen of the Iron Throne and I
think some people are hoping Jon Snow
goes that way there's some theories that
Jon Snow it's an aerosol yeah that's
exactly what I want you want imaginary
those are the two most attractive people
together they'll have dragons and
coolness and like cool kids cousins I
mean with it like removed it's been a
long time since I remove more how much
blood is left in between those two not a
lot right Jaime and Cersei it had
several kids together
yeah alright looks fine if I do look
fine what John and Khaleesi are way more
far removed however totally I'm hoping
John yeah hoping they get John you know
they're both attracted but also John so
is cool as [ __ ] yeah and a good guy and
he's a good fighter and he's just cool
and rad and a leader and so is Khaleesi
would just be like two leaders coming
together to be like we ruled the world
right but they're also like kind like
Jon Snow is a good time you Jon Snow
that's what I'm who doesn't Jon Snow Jon
Snow I mean he's like cool and kind and
he would roll it with an iron fist but
not be a dickwad about it I'm Khaleesi
is the same way where I feel like she
had to kind of step into a territory
which maybe she felt like she went too
far it was just because she had to take
over the land oh yeah totally I think
they're gonna easily take on Cersei I
mean the the Lannisters don't seem to
have the strongest army any not anymore
they just don't they did every
there's losing more hearing was the
brains to all romantic certainly gave
him no [ __ ] respect and now he's gone
and so now you reap your non benefits
so while Cersei is really good at her
manipulation I don't know I just feel
like she can easily be defeated means
they got a dragon man they got [ __ ]
dragons on their dragon I'm saying wait
there's no way they can I hope we don't
lose Jaime and Cersei I mean the show is
not one to shy away from doing something
I know to where we lose oh man oh yeah I
can't even to speak of it now Jaime was
a character that I did not like in the
first couple seasons I did neither I
hated him but when he started getting me
like with Brienne of Tarth and then and
then he like lost his hand as character
started changing and when I really
became one of my favorite characters on
the show I'm hoping we don't lose him
Cersei isn't the one who seems like she
has to go down she's happened it would
be hard to lose her but I would love to
see her die but in a real like
revengeful way where it's like you're
gonna pay for this B word because you're
a B word and have been for years which
of course I'm sure that's what will
happen also I'm excited to see aria
because she's such a badass I love her I
want to see like what role she's going
to be playing in this what's gonna
happen with her cuz she's she was also
in my favorite song with Tyrion in the
first couple of seasons where I was like
she's so cool aria is as strong as
Daenerys and I feel like they have a
similar quality and it would be so cool
also if Jon Snow married
Daenerys right and then his sister comes
back Aria who he loved all along in the
majors like two world and they also have
pet dragons I love the trailer cause
it's not spoiling anything it's showing
like all these characters are returning
it's it's a lot of things we're familiar
with that we want to see return right
it's not really giving away anything
that's a spoiler whatsoever and of
course they're going to do their best to
conceal that yeah but it is showing that
hey our production designs gone bigger
our reality of war epic scenes are
probably going to be a lot crazier the
second to last episode of every season
is a big epic yeah I don't know I know
it yeah I was a crazy battle they always
topped themselves yeah I don't know how
they do that means every time they do is
look Wow
they top it and then they do it again
like I talked indicate yeah and I'm
wondering what is the battle going to be
this time yeah always it always serves a
great plot point and who's going to be
the one involved in the battle I imagine
John Snow but John Stone is usually
involved yeah the show grey worm looks
like he's about to have sex penis list I
don't know how I was gonna do that so
I'm saying but damn that's gonna be hot
the following clip after that are two
women going at it and I can't tell for
the line the images are so sizes an
image here with Jon Snow like choking
someone looks like a woman - yeah I have
no idea like the way the Edit is
together is a lot of those guys what is
going on everyone find out again so good
looks super intense I can't wait for
season 7 to roll around people so
excited I'm gonna do a review of the
first I think every episode I'll do a
review of this time hey guys thanks for
telling me that was out subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
about Tara Ericsson is on the YouTube
channel Nigeria Erik Erikson subscribe
to her channel check out her video check
out the video we did yeah I have other
ideas there idiot I want you to have him
a lot of videos about me don't know I'm
tired of him alright you could just come
over come over here alright get to it
get down with this idiot right rockin
with the idiot army right versus always
real rejects always all the time
everyday hours a day they might need a
break okay this is the last video you'll
ever be on in this channel you
understand I mean I was tired of coming
over here I love with women dirty talk